you know what let's talk about this you
you created Nerdist Empire okay you
probably think I'm guessing I'm guessing
that Chris Hardwick thinks that he is
the king of comic-con but I want to tell
you something okay I hate to take the
starch out of your shorts but when it
comes to comic books when it comes to
superhero movies yeah when it comes to
sci-fi and fantasy characters and all
things nerd there's no bigger expert in
the world than I you're 100% confident
that you can back that up
I can back that up well then you should
have no problem passing this just
invented comic-con citizenship tests
right here let's do it all right all
right
sir please all right here we go
beginning ready go Wolverines claws are
made of what metal adamantium good what
does the acronym shield stand for stands
for strategic homeland intervention
enforcement and logistics division
excellent very well so far who's the
greatest warrior and House Stark Tony
good
and before who wields a purple
lightsaber my dog when he gets too
excited
who is your favorite character on Game
of Thrones whoever is just about to get
killed just number six who is Daredevils
greatest enemy on the even floors that's
very true
seven how does Bruce Banner get ready
for sex he makes his penis angry yes he
does and you wouldn't want to see it
when it's all right
eight if Caitlyn Jenner was a superhero
what team would she be on the x-men yes
what was the right answer number nine
who shot first Han or Greedo neither it
was a Jawa on the grassy knoll all right
number ten who was the hero in the porn
version of The Hobbit dildo shagging
that's correct
number eleven how would note a hit on a
woman get pregnant the first time you
cannot alright it's actually true number
twelve what is Aquaman's superpower
please rephrase the question
what is Aquaman's power again please
rephrase the question
let's Aquaman do talk to fish yeah very
well so far
got a good run next question
cosplay is not drinks with Bill Cosby
all right
that is a 100% true statement number 14
I'm going to name a fictional character
or team and you have to tell me their
famous battle cry first one Thundercats
Thundercats ho good he-man by the power
of Grayskull Ghost Rider the Justice
League
good luck Superman we'll just wait for
you here
next question next question and this is
this is a head scratcher what would you
do if Seth Green suddenly attacked you
with a toy lightsaber well he's not on
the show tonight so I don't think that's
an issue that I'm gonna have to deal
with it anyway
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's true the correct answer was
murdering Seth Green
[Applause]
you
[Music]